you know looking back arthur might not
be the wholesome pbs kids cartoon that
we all thought it was
i mean he had an episode where everyone
in school struggled with addiction to
strange ingredients in the candy bars
that they were eaten that's
certainly concerning and the whole world
seems to operate under unspoken societal
prejudices and hierarchies i mean did
your six-year-old self ever notice the
fact that reptile characters are only
ever shown to be doing jobs with heavy
manual labor it's true it's almost
enough to make you ball up your fist in
anger but there's one other dark truth
about this show
that you might have missed back in
preschool heck that the adults
watching this with their kids have still
missed to this day a dark truth that'll
make your brain
melt and that my friends is what we're
covering today
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that has an original point of
view
just like everyone that you meet when
you're walking down the street here's a
question for you what's the longest
running american cartoon
if you said the simpsons well you
probably also watched our king of the
hill episode and you're right
congratulations but you know what the
second
longest running cartoon in america is
it's our buddy arthur the aardvark who's
been growing up while learning
family-friendly lessons on
tv screens since 1996. this would be the
part where i say
only 90s kids will remember but after 22
seasons
arthur is still on the air it's wild
that my son can grow up watching the
same shows that were on tv when i was a
kid
and i'm glad that arthur never left
cause every kid ought to grow up in a
world where we can learn to work
and play and get along with each other
arthur's also one of those shows that's
great to go back to as an adult cause a
lot of the jokes were totally put in
there for the parents who had to watch
whatever their kids were watching and if
you were a kid well you probably missed
a lot of those references the first time
around
sorry sue ellen it's a brother and
sister race maybe there's a contest for
lonely children after this
it's only children dw a lonely child is
what you're gonna be when i sell you
holy jeez arthur when you sell
your sister what am i gonna do run away
literally join the circus my mom knows a
good plastic surgeon but there's another
thing that you might have missed when
watching arthur as a kid
something that's not so bright and
cheery it may be a wonderful kind of day
but we wouldn't be film theory if we
weren't willing to ruin those wholesome
childhood memories by exposing the dark
and tragic truths behind them now if
you're somehow one of the people who
didn't grow up watching this pbs classic
as a kid arthur is a show about an
aardvark named arthur and his sister dw
as they go to school with their friends
including a rabbit named buster a monkey
named francine a bulldog named binky a
bear named the brain
everyone in the world is an animal in
case you missed the pattern
and um that's pretty much what you need
to know in typical kids show fashion
they learn life lessons
they shade each other you know how polly
lock it works that's where you keep your
most special important thing
i figured you'd want to put this in
there no thanks
i'm gonna put in a picture of my cat oh
and they burn the spelling of aardvark
into your brain so completely that
literal decades after you watch that one
episode
you still hear it in your mind
a-a-r-d-v-a-r-k
a-a-r-d-b-a-r-k
no joke it is still how i remember how
to spell that word even as i'm typing
this up that song
is playing constantly in the back of my
brain and that's what you get if you're
the target demographic but if you've
ever stumbled across an episode of this
show as someone a bit older
after learning about the birds and the
bees you might be wondering
how in a society of animals inner
species romance works but ha
jokes on you the show is already one
step ahead of you despite arthur living
in a society with many different types
of animals
most families seem to be single species
arthur and his sister dw are both
aardvarks and both of their parents are
also aardvarks buster baxter is a rabbit
with two rabbit parents
francine is a monkey with two monkey
parents and so on and so
forth now we do know that inner species
romance isn't exactly taboo for instance
back in 2019
mr ratburn who you might have already
guessed is a rat
married and aardvark and while that
episode was apparently controversial
enough to get it banned from television
in
alabama i'm gonna wager that the outrage
was more about the fact that mr ratburn
was a man marrying another man
and not so much the fact that it was a
rat marrying an aardvark
in this world there's apparently nothing
saying that an aardvark can't date
or marry a rat but when it comes to
biology and reproduction
the arthur universe seems to follow
rules pretty similar to our own
if you're an aardvark looking to make
some aardvark babies you're gonna have
to find yourself another aardvark or at
least
that's the way it seems at first until
you start digging deeper
and you notice a strange trend for
instance molly and james mcdonald
they're both rabbits
and while their father is a rabbit their
mom is a dog
emily here is also a rabbit with a
rabbit mother and a monkey
father and carl is a rabbit who has an
aardvark mother and no other parents
that we can see
at first these three examples might seem
to disprove the idea that interspecies
romance in the arthur universe can't
result in reproduction but there's
another thing that they all have in
common molly
james emily and carl the four characters
who all have at least one parent that
doesn't match their own species are all
rabbits that doesn't seem like it can be
a coincidence in a world full of
aardvarks monkeys bulldogs and all other
kinds of animal species it
just so happens that the kids who have
parents of different species
all are predominantly rabbits when you
see a pattern like that it's the kind of
thing that raises questions
and demands answers the first question i
had is whether there might be some
particular quirk of rabbit biology that
might allow him to breed across species
it's not unheard of for there to be
genetic hybrids after all for instance
you may have heard of mules
well they're the offspring of a horse
and a donkey there's also many varieties
of zebroids which result in
cross-breeding zebras with other species
you know what you get when you cross a
zebra in a horse
a zorse what do you get when you cross a
zebra in a donkey a zonkey and those
aren't jokes those are actual real
animals that can be created
via crossbreeding we assumed that molly
james emily and carl were all rabbits
based on their distinctive rabbit-like
features but could it be that they're
the result of some kind of crossbreeding
well the science
doesn't seem to support it rabbits
aren't genetically similar enough to
dogs monkeys or
aardvarks to crossbreed with them you
could argue that the arthur universe has
different rules here after all all the
animals are genetically similar enough
to walk
upright on two feet and speak to each
other in english but even if that were
the case it still doesn't explain why
it's only
rabbits that we see as the children in
these inner species relationships
however there may indeed be a biological
explanation for why it's always
rabbits who seem to be raised by
non-rabbit parents and it gets into some
territory that has some pretty troubling
implications for the wider
arthur universe one thing that we've
been doing this whole time is operating
under the assumption that
all of these rabbit kids are the
biological children of the parents that
they live with but as we all know the
real world is full of plenty of examples
where parents and children
aren't related by blood obviously
adoption exists and there are plenty of
kids with divorced parents living with
their
step parents in short the way i see it
there are two key possibilities
potentially causing this trend
one divorce is more common in rabbit
couples or two
rabbit children are getting put up for
adoption more frequently so let's start
with possibility one divorce being
common in rabbit couples you see this
theory already seems plausible
considering that divorce
exists in arthur's world buster baxter
has parents who are separated
also a rabbit couple and there's a real
world explanation for this you see real
world rabbits don't tend to mate with
only one partner for their entire
lifetime
they're not monogamous you could say
that they are hopping from partner to
partner which you know could produce
some strain on a relationship when bitsy
baxter over there is finding her husband
beau in the borough with another woman
except there's a problem with all this
rabbits aren't alone in this category
very very few animal species are
actually monogamous
it's mostly because it doesn't make
sense from a genetic standpoint
reproduction is all about ensuring the
survival of your genes into the next
generation
so you want as many chances at that as
possible with a relatively wide array of
mates monogamy is costly because it
requires an individual to place their
entire reproductive investment on the
fitness
of their one mate it's putting all their
eggs in one basket
literally and in arthur we see all
different animal types from aardvarks to
bulldogs
goats monkeys moose pigs sheep in all i
counted about 20 different species of
animal shown to be functioning members
of this society and the fact is
most of these types of animals would be
dealing with the same marital issues if
monogamy was really a concern in this
universe
so it doesn't seem like divorce here is
causing the issue
which means it has to roll up to option
two adoption
but why would so many bunny babies be
put up for adoption in this universe
well i think it's actually the result of
two contributing factors you see it's no
secret that rabbits are notorious for
their mating abilities the phrase
breeding like rabbits is a thing that
exists for a good reason
rabbits are able to become pregnant
early in life with some species able to
get the ball rolling so to speak
as early as four months of age add to
that the fact that the female is able to
get pregnant for all but
three days per month and you've got
yourself a wide open window for babies
now that alone would be pretty unique in
the animal kingdom but there's another
few factors that make
rabbits incredible breeders you see a
mother rabbit usually gives birth within
32 days of getting pregnant and is ready
to get pregnant again
almost immediately after giving birth so
if they wanted
a mother rabbit could have a litter of
babies almost every month
nearly 12 in a year which is incredible
compare that to humans where the
gestational period is 266 days but what
makes
rabbit breeding truly insane is that
each of those litters can have anywhere
between 1
and 14 babies with the average being
six compare that to other animals that
we see in the arthur universe aardvarks
one baby every seven months
monkeys one baby every two years or so
dogs cats foxes bears you name it all of
them have longer pregnancies and smaller
litters
which means that there's going to be a
lot more rabbits in this world than
there are
any other type of animal and this is
something that's actually confirmed by
the show's character list
looking through lists of all characters
to have ever appeared in arthur you
quickly see that there are nearly
220 unique rabbit characters that have
shown up on the screen
the second most animal species is as
you'd expect aardvarks which clock in at
around 170 unique characters but that
number is also inflated since our main
character is himself in aardvark so the
show is going to revolve around him and
his animal type
no other animal even comes close to
touching the number of rabbit characters
in this show
now it'd be tempting to say that all
these newborn bunnies are resulting in
the parents abandoning some of their
kids which is terrible
and awful and quite honestly would make
a pretty darn good dark twist for this
episode on a show made for elementary
school kids but i don't think that's the
case here there isn't any scientific
evidence suggesting that rabbit parents
are any more negligent than parents of
other species and it also won't explain
why there are so many
one rabbit households now i think that
there's something else at play here you
see
there is one basic bit of biology that
separates rabbits from pretty much every
other species that we see on the show
lifespan let's go back to that character
frequency chart shall we and compare the
life spans of the most common species
that we see in the arthur universe
aardvarks 18 years in the wild
23 in captivity brown bear 20 to 25
years in the wild
dogs 10 to 15 years depending on the
breed indoor cats 13 to 17 years brown
spider monkeys 27 years in the wild 33
in captivity
rabbit one to two years in the wild five
to seven
in captivity to borrow from another kids
program one of these
things is not like the others in the
world of arthur animal lifespans are
probably going to be closer to what they
would be in captivity since arthur and
his classmates probably don't have to
worry about things like natural
predators of course i missed that
episode where the brain has to learn to
suppress his bear-like instincts to
avoid devouring his classmates but even
when raised in captivity
rabbits have a much shorter life span
than aardvarks monkeys
dogs and pretty much every other species
that we see up here in arthur with the
only big exception being rats but then
again
this is a third grade rat in arthur dude
already looks like he's ready to put a
mortgage on a house so i'd say he's
agent pretty darn
fast now obviously everything that we
see in the arthur universe isn't going
to be one to one with real life these
animals can stand upright on two legs to
walk down the street and can learn to
work and play and get along with each
other these animals seem to age at a
rate similar to humans while real-life
rabbits are capable of breeding at ages
as young as four to six months buster is
eight years old and doesn't seem to have
hit puberty yet so if we adjust animal
life spans to human lifespans like we
see on the show it would look a little
something like this
aardvarks 97 years brown bear 95 years
dogs 42 to 63 years depending on the
breed cats
63 years monkeys 139 years
rabbits 24 to 42 and this my friends
explains the thing that sent us down
this rabbit hole in the first place
which is why there are so many rabbits
who seem to have guardians of other
species or just live in single rabbit
families the simple fact is that even if
rabbits are starting families at ages as
young as
18 a significant portion of them won't
live long enough to see their kids
finish school with rabbit lifespan so
short it's no wonder that so many rabbit
kids are being raised by non-rabbits the
surviving rabbit parent probably
remarries out of desire to have a
partner to raise kids with
them if this is common in the arthur
universe it wouldn't be all that weird
for this sort of thing to happen which
would explain why it's never commented
on by characters in the show
arthur has been on the air since 1996
and he's just one of those cartoon
characters that doesn't age he's been an
eight-year-old third grader for over 23
years which
gotta say it's probably a good thing if
the series actually followed the
characters for 23 years they might have
already gotten to the point where
buster's classmates have to hold his
funeral
while everyone else is in the prime of
their lives that of course would be
after the episode where buster goes
through his midlife crisis somewhere in
the middle of high school
looking at all the life expectancies for
the animals in the arthur universe
arthur the aardvark actually has a
pretty decent shot of outliving most of
his other classmates maybe
he really should marry francine the
monkey if he's looking for someone to
spend his golden years with oh wait he
actually does this is something that is
confirmed in the show
they do wind up together and strangely
have a conversation about buster
there's buster baxter whatever happened
to him
huh whatever happened to buster strange
how those best friends don't wind up
together in the end and notice how
arthur just doesn't respond in this
moment he just
stares sadly off into the distance it's
almost like he had a dear old friend who
died a bit too early
and that my friends is my feel good
episode on the world of arthur happy
childhoods and remember
it's all just a theory a film theory
and this episode was brought to you by
the subscribe button the subscribe
button helping this channel reach an
arbitrary milestone that will get us a
glorified paperweight
subscribe button use it
ark